How Can We End Poverty?
Whenever I talk about microcredit,...
...people say things like, "I'm sorry, could you repeat that?"
...or "Could you run that by me again?"
I guess not many people have heard of it.
Microcredit is a great way to help poor people lift themselves out of poverty.
It is a system that offers loans under 200 dollars without collateral...
...and has changed the lives of millions of people worldwide.
About 50% of the world population lives under poverty...
...and struggles to survive on a daily basis.
But there can be so many creative ways that you can make a difference in the lives of the poor.
What can you do to help create a poverty - free world?
Any ideas?
I think many of the problems of the developing nations have to do with infrastructure.
If there are no roads, food, medicine and other needed goods and services cannot reach the people.
At some point, it is the responsibility of a good government...
...to employ people to build roads and water purification systems and other necessary facilities.